hallo herzlich will kann man den wald
orten welt heute bekommt ihr das video
mit der hochzeitstorte und zwar habe ich
dir für den kollegen meines mannes
gebacken und es sollte einfach mal eine
außergewöhnliche torte sein es sollte
einfach mal mit orte ohne fondant werden
und deswegen habe ich mich dazu
entschlossen dieses mal mit modelle
schokolade zu arbeiten und die torte mit
früchten zu dekorieren ich werde euch
jetzt in diesem video nicht zeigen wie
ich die hürden gebacken habe das nämlich
ganz normal ist mit bögen und ich habe
dazu mal ein video gemacht aber ich habe
mein rezept für den whisky zeit
verändert und zeigt euch das einfach mal
ein anderes mal
ich werde direkt in dem video starten
mit der füllung und zwar mache ich eine
hinweg unter creme die übrigens für
total lecker ist ich war normalerweise
nichts oder buttercreme fällen aber so
eine fruchtige buttercreme ich wirklich
was sehr leckeres und ich hab das ganze
noch getoppt mit einer himbeere frucht
einlage wie ihr sie auch schon aus der
taucht heute kennt habe ich auch eine
frucht einlage gemacht und ich würde
sagen ich starte jetzt einfach mal mit
der frucht einlage und mit autokränen
ich habe jetzt hier 800 gramm himbeer
die sind tiefgefroren ihr könnt aber
natürlich auch frische himbeeren
benutzen
hier habe ich 200 gramm zucker da kann
es aber sein dass ich nicht den
kompletten zucker brauche es kommt
einfach darauf an wie süße himbeeren
sind
ich brauche 200 gramm wasser und ich
brauche entweder gelatine oder catherine
entweder nimmt ihr 18 bachelor tine oder
in drei päckchen magazine und ich nehme
es heute die ak tine wenn ihr aber
gelatine nehmen müsst ihr auf meinem
blog nachlesen wie da die zubereitung
ist
magazine ist es so dass eine tüte aka
tine sechs blättern gelatine entspricht
und da wir 18 blätter gelatine brauchen
sind es drei päckchen akademie die in
bern lasse ich jetzt in einem topf
langsam auftauen
das könnt ihr natürlich auch
beispielsweise über nacht machen dann
kommt das wasser dazu der zucker ich
nehme jetzt noch nicht alles da müsst
ihr einfach mal abschmecken und dann
gibt die ak team mit dazu und wird das
ganze klümpchen frei und lasst es dann
auf dem herd aufkochen
diese masse muss etwa zwei minuten lang
auf kochen damit die aktive wirken kann
und dann gebe ich sie in meine
vorbereiteten drei förmchen und diese
haben jeweils 2 cm weniger durchmesser
als meine discrete böden oder ihnen
beispielsweise back rahmen
die müssen aber auch zwei zentimeter
kleiner sein diese mischung lasse ich
dann einfach bei zimmertemperatur stehen
bis sie geliert ist und früher sie dann
ein so dass ich später einen harten
frucht kern habe den ich verwenden kann
für die himbeer buttercreme brauche ich
eins bis 15 kilo himbeeren das sind es
weder tiefgefrorene himbeeren und
hierbei brauche ich den himbeersaft das
heißt ihr können beispielsweise auch
einfach nur saft nehmen und davon
brauche ich ein liter
wenn ich jetzt aus den himba nicht ganz
einen liter heraus bekomme will ich es
einfach mit wasser oder mit etwas milch
oder sahne auf das könnt ihr einfach
selber entscheiden
hier könnt ihr beispielsweise auch ein
anderes obst nehmen oder einfach wie
gesagt einen fruchtsaft dann brauche ich
noch 200 gramm zucker wenn ich jetzt ein
süßes obst habe nehme ich da auch etwas
weniger zucker ich brauche 80 gramm
eigelbe das ist jetzt das eigelb von
sechs eier und das eiweiß brauche ich an
dieser stelle nicht dass beweis aber in
nordeuropa schüssel auf und kann damit
beispielsweise pc herstellen
aber für dieses rezept brauche ich nicht
ich brauche 80 g speisestärke eine gute
prise salz und 640 gramm zimmer warme
butter
die brauche ich erst zum späteren
zeitpunkt und stellt sie deswegen auch
kurz zur seite um den fruchtsaft aus den
himbeeren jetzt aufzufangen gebe ich
einen sieg über einen topf und gäbe da
die himbeeren hinein
und weil es so den saft auffangen die
himbeeren die dann im sieb übrigbleiben
müsst ihr nicht wegschmeißen
die könnt ihr beispielsweise später in
einen joghurt vermischen und aufessen
oder einfach zu einer schorle
weiterverarbeiten und ich gebe da immer
mal wieder etwas wasser oben mit rein
und vermische schön damit zu viel frucht
muss wie möglich in den saft übergeht
anschließend verlor ich die stärke die
eigelbe und den zucker mit dem
himbeersaft und gibt es ganze auf den
herd und lass es bei mittlerer stufe
dicklich einkochen
das dauert ein paar minuten und wenn es
dann einmal aufgekocht ist das muss man
ganz vorsichtig machen damit sich da
keine klümpchen auch bilden dann könnt
ihr es vom herd unternehmen und dann ist
der pudding fertig diesen fühle ich dann
in einen großen flachen behälter um und
decke ihnen direkt über den pudding mit
folie ab und lass das ganze bei
zimmertemperatur abkühlen und wird
anschließend durch ein sieb streichen
damit ich einfach etwaige klümpchen eben
nicht mehr mit drin habe
inzwischen gebe ich die butter in der
große rührschüssel und lasse richtig
schön weiß cremig schlagen und dann
kommt nach und nach löffelweise meine
hinnehmbar pudding mit dazu so dass ich
zum schluss eine leckere himberg habe
diese gebe ich kurz in den kühlschrank
und lässt sie gleich weiter verwenden
in der zwischenzeit stelle ich auch
schon mal meine ghana schwer
und zwar habe ich hier für die sahne in
einen kleinen topf gegeben und auf den
herd gestellt und habe hier etwa 200
gramm sahne und 600 gramm weiße
schokolade
ich habe diese menge allerdings schon
zwei mal gemacht das heißt insgesamt
traurig für die torte 600 gramm sahne
und 1800 gramm schokolade die sahne wird
dann auf dem herd aufgekocht und
anschließend die sich sie über die weiße
schokolade und rührt dann einfach so
lange bis sich die weiße schokolade
komplett aufgelöst hat ich brauchte auch
gar keinen mixa dazu sondern es geht
eigentlich alles durch ständige höhe und
sobald sich dann alles aufgelöst hat
werde ich die ganz abdecken und einfach
bei zimmertemperatur stehen lassen bis
sie vollständig abgekühlt ist meine
vorbereiteten bizkit böden gebe ich
jetzt auf meine vorbereiteten kaaba
platten und klebt sie damit etwas ganz
fest
die durchmesser der torten sind 14 20
und 26 cm die bizkit böden schneide ich
zweimal durch so dass sich insgesamt
drei bilden habe und jetzt können die
torten befüllt werden
die erste schicht besteht aus der himmel
buttercreme die streiche ich jetzt auf
einen boden drauf gibt den zweiten boden
drauf und streiche eine dünne schicht
von der himmel buttercreme drauf damit
es anschließend die gefrorene frucht
einlage reinlegen
diese decke ich dann noch mal mit etwas
himmel butter themen und lege den
letzten boden drauf bei der größten form
habe ich sogar noch einen vierten boden
gebacken so dass die torte unten eben
schön hoch wird
das ganze richtig dann noch mit der
wasserwaage aus und stellt dann für 30
minuten in den kühlschrank
anschließend kann ich die torte mit der
garage überdecken
das mache ich ihnen mehreren schritten
im ersten schritt werde ich die
oberfläche und die seiten mit der garage
überdecken und etwas glatt streichen und
immer mal wieder für 15 minuten kühl
stellen
irgendwann ist die torte dann an den
seiten sehr glatt und ihr könnt die
kupferplatte auf der oberseite entferne
und muss dann nur noch die oberseite der
torte klatschen reicht
die torte habe ich jetzt gefüllt und mit
gage eingestrichen und im nächsten
schritt kommt jetzt auch schon die
dekoration
ich habe jetzt nur leider in den kleinen
fehler und zwar habe ich die taten ja
bis mitten in die nacht um 3 gepackten
und irgendwie habe ich ja da gerade drei
torten auf einmal gebacken und inwieweit
total im trocken backen und habe einfach
auch die hochzeitstorte mich von dort
überzogen und dann im nachhinein erst am
nächsten tag festgestellt dass sich das
damit machen sollte also ihr braucht für
die torte weg ist kennt von dorf sondern
könnte jetzt die torte mit ghanas nehmen
und diese dann einfach weiter dekorieren
ich habe jetzt einfach leider den fehler
gemacht und habe den vorgang aber auch
nicht mehr entfernt
das war mir einfach zu riskant dass ich
da die oberfläche mit wegnehmen und habe
einfach jetzt auf dem von dort weiter
dekoriert und ja es war etwas dusselig
von mir aber ich hab da einfach nicht
drüber nachgedacht mit minder nacht und
ich zeige euch einfach mal wie es mit
der modellierte collage weitergeht zum
fertig stellen gebe ich jetzt meine
größte torte auf einen cache bord und
krebs einfach mit etwas ganz fest
und werde mir jetzt ein paar hilfslinien
sehen in dem ich meine kappe platte oder
cache bord nehmen und damit den platz
der zweiten torte eben an zeichne die
torte wird dann gestützt mit ein paar
holz döbeln die ich mir noch zurecht
schneiden muss das habe ich auch in
meinem bauch torten video gezeigt der
holzstab mit hinein gesteckt und mit
einem stift abgemessen und dann schneide
ich mir ganz viele holz dübel zu recht
die so hoch sind wie die torte steckt
diese hinein damit die oberen torten
nicht in die untere torte hinein singen
die moderne schokolade vertrete ich
jetzt zwischen den händen damit sie warm
wird und formbar wert und rollen sie mit
einem kleinen auswahl starb ganz lang
aus
um schneide eine gerade fläche weg und
schneidet die modelle schokolade dann
etwas in wellen und drücke die kanten
oben mit meinen fingern etwas flach und
dünne sie aus
die torte könnt ihr dann mit etwas
realizing also zuckerglasur bestreichen
damit die schokolade daran haften bleibt
aber im normalfall bleibt sie auch
einfach aus der garage haften
und dann könnt ihr die modelle
schokolade einfach nur mit den fingern
formen und das gute an ihr ist und auch
das ist der große vorteil den sie hat
man kann die modelle schokolade im
nachhinein immer wieder weiter formen
bis man komplett zufrieden ist also
selbst wenn sie schon erstarrt ist wenn
sie kalt ist kann man sie mit den
fingern wieder wahr machen und einfach
wieder umformen
und am besten beginnt ihr jetzt immer
oben am rand und zählt da einen rand und
arbeitet euch dann von oben nach unten
mit den streifen entlang und legt sie so
immer zwischen rein so dass eben keine
weißen rändern sichtbar sind
die arbeit mit der modelle schokolade
habe ich jetzt bereits einen tag vor der
hochzeit fertiggestellt sodass die torte
in der nacht im kühlschrank stand und am
nächsten tag konnte ich dann die früchte
darauf platzieren
am frühesten habe ich thrombin himbeeren
dunkle trauben helle trauben
heidelbeeren johannisbeeren physalis und
auf stern.de habe ich etwas kuvertüre
fein gerieben und habe die cache bord
platte mit etwas racing bestrichen und
konnte einen kleinen brand aus modelle
schokolade formen und habe dann die
komplette platte mit den schokostreuseln
bestreut
anschließend habe ich auch jede torte
noch mal mit etwas racing bestritten und
konnte dann ganz einfach die früchte
bunt gemischt auf die torte draufsetzen
da müsst ihr einfach darauf achten dass
keine lücken entstehen und dass die
torte komplett mit den früchten belegt
ist
die früchte müssen natürlich kurz vor
dem servieren aufbringen also ich hab
sie am gleichen tag der hochzeit auf der
torte eben drauf auf die torte
draufgesetzt und natürlich ist es beim
anschneiden so dass er dann
wahrscheinlich die früchte mit
anschneidet und darstellern vielleicht
nicht mehr ganz so schön ist aber ich
finde die torte ist somit den früchten
und mit der schokolade außenrum echten
highlight und gefällt mir auch sehr gut
und sie war sicherlich auch stärker mit
dieser team buttercreme ich hoffe dass
euch die torte gefallen hat und dass er
vielleicht die ein oder andere idee auch
mal umsetzen könnt und ich euch einfach
eine anregung geben konnte und ich
wünsche euch noch ganz viel spaß beim
akku und dekorieren und falls ihr das
video mit der model ihr chocolat so noch
nicht gesehen habt könnt ihr das jetzt
gleich anklicken und ich wünsche euch
allen noch einen ganz schönen tag für
falsch